[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to Hollywood we are
here on the Warner Brothers lot to bring
you an Oscar special this of course is
home to many classic movies over the
years and it's where many of the scenes
were shot for the film that everyone's
talking about at the moment
lala land these dreams that we keep
running into each other well the Academy
of course was always going to love a
film about Hollywood but how does this
film compare them to the Golden Age
classics I thought I'd look into the
work that went into making la la land
attempting to recreate the magic of the
Hollywood musical was pretty brave could
it ever live up to the Golden Age it
started certainly put the legwork in a
three-month boot camp to master dancing
singing and for Ryan Gosling learning to
play the jazz piano the director Damien
Chazelle wanted to shoot the dance
sequences some of the songs and and some
of these nice piano pieces all in one
shot so there was no opportunity to kind
of cut in the proper piano player so
unless I wanted to shatter his dreams I
had to sit down and apply myself
[Music]
but not everyone's convinced these
musical theater students were rather
underwhelmed I don't think they're
particularly challenging songs I think I
think because they were written for
actors rather than for musical theater
performers they made them simpler I
think it might be remembered just
possibly for the awards that it's won
but as a musical it wouldn't be up there
with her with the great ones
definitely not if you keep your fingers
on the same note as for learning the
jazz piano the music has been written in
a way that actually makes it reasonably
straightforward to learn so for example
if you put your hand in a particular
place on the keyboard you can actually
play the whole phrase without moving
your hand once and those are the tricks
that a good writer will be able to use
Ryan had three months I thought I'd give
it a go in three weeks if you have a
better keyboard I'm sure that we could
get you doing
if la-la-land had taught me anything it
was to dream big Hollywood was calling
of course in Tinseltown everyone just
breaks into dance
it's a recognizable routine for musical
efficient our days so canal and really
compete with Fred Astaire's finesse and
could I compete with Ryan today we have
Katie from London who has played cello
for only three weeks and she's here for
the ask us one of her film crew and
she's going to do a special song for you
there's an oscar-winning song don't get
it Katie
[Applause]
[Music]
okay Ryan maybe it's a little harder
than it looks well joining me now is
entertainment reporter Amy Nicholson now
Amy the excitement over lala land began
very early on with this filmed in there
why has it made such an impact I think
with lala land what you're seeing is a
film that looked unlike anything else
that we usually think of when we think
of what a best picture is we think of
the film that serious has historical
impact it's a drama it has a true life
angle to it la the land is a lite-brite
musical starring two of the biggest
movie stars of their generation you have
Ryan Gosling and Emma Stone actors that
people love and then combining them in
something that's colorful and a musical
and feels fresh again I think got a lot
of attention right when it started
playing festivals the fact that we have
been talking about this film now for
months and months do you think to an
extent perhaps that could damage its
chances on Sunday we're a bit fatigued
with talking about lala land what we've
seen happen in the last few months in
America is kind of a tonal shift where
we're wondering do we want to see a
bright comedy like lalala and reflect us
something dreamy that says that this is
what America is all about
or our voters may be getting ready to
honor something that feels more like
what America is today something more
serious like moonlight and I think we're
starting to see that conversation shift
back a little in moonlights favor and if
we take lala land really for what it is
then a musical how do you think when we
look back on this time in a few years
time it'll compare to some of the
Great's that we've had well it's
interesting because as you know lala
land set an Academy record along with
All About Eve and Titanic these films
have 14 nominations each they're tied
for the most number of nominations of
all time that's all about Eve and that's
Titanic I mean these are two huge movies
in the history of classic cinema I love
Titanic I don't know how you feel
and I can't help but think that Long
Island doesn't quite measure up to that
level it's a cute film and it's a
charming film and I can get someone a
lot of people's parts this year
but I don't think it's going to last in
the same way that those other films have
but yet the history books might make it
seem just as important well of course
there are a lot of other films that are
nominated this Sunday and Robbie Collin
our film critic has been talking me
through some of the nominees dream this
is the dream conflict and it's
compromised it's very very exciting
it is the film that everyone's been
talking about isn't it la la Ladd now
goes down into the Oscar history books
if you like as well the nominations yes
the most nominations ever tied with
Titanic and all about and it just
immediately struck everyone as a worthy
Best Picture winner first of always
Hollywood kind of celebrating itself
that's looking back to all styles of
filmmaking the you know the Golden Age
of the MGM musical it's also updating
that and it's moving it on and saying
these are techniques and styles of
entertainment but are still completely
relevant and moving and exciting and
funny in the modern world is anything
else gonna sort of come close you've got
la-la land
you've got Manchester by the sea and
then also moonlight which was this kind
of art house festival circuit
runaway success but a young guy who's
who's black and gay growing up in Miami
at some point you got a desire for
yourself food you know
they let nobody make that decision it's
very delicate and beautifully composed I
think it leads to an Oscar race this
year that is in many ways incredibly
diverse that was a big thing last year
wasn't it the Oscars so white debate
it's a very different field this year
though that we're seeing much more
diverse I mean for the last few years
all of the acting nominees were white
and this year there are six non-white
contenders across the four categories so
I think the efforts that the Academy has
been going to to make sure the diversity
of its membership matches up with the
diversity of cinema itself or at least
begins to reflect the fruit of that is
now being seen in the people and the
films are being nominated talk us
through the British nominees then who
we've seen this year Andrew Garfield and
Noemi Harris has been nominated for
moonlight I'm probably most excited
about Dev Patel being nominated and Best
Supporting Actor for a lion he has real
leading-man charm in this and you sense
this is a real step up career-wise for
him it's certainly gonna be a very
interesting ceremony thank you so much
Rob economy for talking to us thank you
well Amy Nicholson is still with me Amy
come on there now - this year's nominees
what do you want to see win Best Picture
I don't there's nine I think I'd like to
see it go to moonlight we haven't had a
Best Picture like moonlight ever I mean
this is a film that talks about a
character we don't get to see on film a
young black gay man living in Florida
and it's also a film that tells the
story in a totally different way by
using three different actors to play
this character throughout his life if we
honor that we're honoring something that
I think is brand new and fresh and
really represents what what's happening
right now in Hollywood I have to say
personally my favorite has to be lion
and Dev Patel Britain's own is up for
Best Supporting Actor and I had the very
good fortune of catching up with him
just a few weeks ago to chat about that
role you're from Calcutta which body I'm
adopted I'm not willing I mean deeply
emotional incredibly cinematic lion has
put Dev Patel firmly back on Hollywood's
radar with a role that's captivated
critics it's kind of a journey that any
young actor dieter to go on you know and
for me being a you know British Asian it
kind of opposes
a real departure from the usual roles
that I you know I get given or I'm up
for it has a real weight to the journey
have to find my way back home it's based
on an extraordinary true story as a
five-year-old in India cerebrally
wanders alone onto a train losing his
family he's eventually adopted by an
Australian couple but never loses the
niggling guilt that his mum and brother
might still be looking for him he was
suppressing a part of his Indian roots
his culture so he could fit in in
Australia and that's something that I
did growing up here in London you know
when I went to school and it was only
when I went to shoot some dog that I
really experienced this country and
could really appreciate it death was
just 17 when he made the movie that
introduced him to the world in 2009
Slumdog won eight Oscars but after the
award ceremonies were over he struggled
to find work
it was criticized for taking on some
questionable roles you don't want to be
attacked for playing who you are
sometimes like I'm a British agent so
you know when the dialogue is that are
he's just playing in an Indian guy like
wait a minute you you wouldn't crucified
DeNiro for playing an Italian would you
so why is that seen as a hindrance now
26 Dev Patel is older and wiser the
journey to making lion has taught him a
lot if it was all success I and may be a
very different person it's this it's
very humbling when you come off such a
big experience and then face a big
failure or something but it makes you
also appreciate when stories like this
come around and that's why I ended up
knocking on the screenwriters dorkus
I wanted it so bad coming up we look at
how the Academy has responded to last
year's race route and whether or not the
ceremony itself could be hijacked by a
certain politician hello and welcome
back to Hollywood we're on the set of
lala land for an Oscar special and aside
from the films this year our West Coast
correspondent Greg Milam has been
looking at the fact that this year's
ceremony looks set to be particularly
politically charged Donald Trump's star
on the Hollywood Walk of Fame was taped
over this week security say to protect
it from red carpet damage but just along
from the Oscars venue it's also perhaps
a metaphor for what Hollywood thinks at
the new president what started with
Meryl Streep's condemnation at the
Golden Globes will reach Hollywood's
biggest stage and whoever protests will
have the backing of the president of the
Academy one thing that we're all happy
about is that we have freedom of speech
it makes it very human I think right
because it's at the moment
and no one knows with what name is going
to be read off the envelope so it's
pretty spontaneous
and I I I think and I hope that those on
stage will give us a 45 seconds of
something really meaningful and touching
but there are nominees who won't be
protest
if they win unfortunately celebrity
culture has gotten to the point where
celebrities voice is more meaningful
than other people's in certain ways and
that's that's a shame that shouldn't be
the case for me from my perspective I'm
not a big fan of that as a cultural as a
cultural state that we're in watching
millions have seen political protests at
the Oscars before 1973 was the first
time anyone had gotten political about
the Oscars and marlon brando had won the
Best Actor Award for The Godfather and
he but boycotted the awards and sent
Sacheen Littlefeather to speak out
against the way Native Americans were
portrayed by Hollywood in films and
television this is Michael Moore he took
the opportunity to to criticize George W
Bush for the Iraq war and but got booed
off the stage really so Leonardo
DiCaprio had just won his first Oscar it
was for the revenant for Best Actor
he emphasized climate change is real and
it affects the indigenous people and and
and and everyone these folks have given
us countless hours of entertainment for
us to give them 30 seconds to speak on
an important issue I think is a fair
trade Donald Trump wasn't always so
unpopular here they did after all give
him that star for his work on The
Apprentice and remember this is a man
who once said his first ambition in life
was to be a Hollywood movie mogul
there's no doubt we will hear plenty
about him at the Oscars he hasn't taken
kindly to Hollywood's criticisms so far
you might want to find something else to
watch this weekend well Greg joins me
now Greg then do we think President
Trump is going to be back on Twitter
then this Sunday when he watches the the
ceremony itself I think we I think we're
pretty certain that he will be it may
well be that we see real-time tweeting
from the Oval Office on the Oscars for
the first time in history because we saw
before how offended he was by what Meryl
Streep said at the Golden Globes and
calling her overrated he couldn't he
couldn't help but respond to criticism
which is something symptomatic of Donald
Trump the president so I think yeah
there's so much at stake there's so much
discussion
about him and what he means to the
United States I think it's it's
impossible to believe that he he won't
come up during the ceremony and
impossible to believe that he won't
respond if he does because we've seen in
the past he's rather thin-skinned about
these things there is a certain irony
isn't there to him being at loggerheads
with Hollywood because this is a world
that he loves I mean he over the years
he's had bit parts in films hasn't he of
course he it was the star of The
Apprentice he loves this world at the
same time as sort of being up against it
yeah and remember he said that his first
ambition wasn't to go into real estate
like his father his first ambition was
to become a Hollywood movie mogul to
come to this place sets like this and
and and make movies and become a big
deal in in Hollywood and it didn't
happen things turned out rather
differently for anyone but yeah he's he
is someone who understands the
entertainment industry and understands
how to make a success out of being in
the entertainment industry and I think
understands what's going on with with
the industry in their view of him and I
think that hurts him because this is a
place that he wants to be accepted and
the thought that he's not is very
difficult for him
who had these sort of pampered
privileged Hollywood types to be
speaking out does it actually affect
them do they have a legitimate reason to
be speaking out do you think depends are
you asked some think they've got a
responsibility to do it that these are
issues that affect them just as they
affect everyday Americans and people
around the world but there are those
like Andrew Garfield will say that the
celebrities have been elevated to a
position of having ever having this this
role and there's this greater saying
that that's that's not right and it's
impossible to think that people won't
mention Donald Trump on the stage from
the host down and it's impossible to
think he won't respond because history
tells us he generally does and it's not
just politics on the agenda this time
last year the Oscars so white debate
controversy really just exploded this
year however though it's a very
different picture we may lose a small
battles but win the big war he who is
you know buddy I told him if he wasn't a
man kind and move out the ways of the
mankind could fine me looking at this
year's standout hopefuls you could
almost forget last year's Oscars so
white race RAL sparked by two years of
entirely white acting nominees this year
however there are nods for seven
non-white actors
here in Hollywood the Academy was forced
to introduce 683 new members in an
effort to diversify and it seems to have
had an effect moonlights the moving
story of a gay black boy from Miami is
up for eight Oscars this weekend it's a
film that in the past might have been
overlooked I think people have sought
out the film you know as a very I think
honest depiction of a certain a certain
version of the American life that is
just as valid as other versions other
depictions of American life the only
difference is this version you know
isn't given voice very often why you
didn't come home Naomi Harris was
hesitant about playing a crack addict
mum reluctant to play stereotypes I'd
always said that I wanted to use my
career to portray positive images of
women because I felt them you know my
mother is an incredibly inspirational
figure in my life and I I thought I grew
up in a community of very strong
intelligent capable women but I didn't
see them reflected on screen students
that this drama school in London
couldn't be more pleased with this
year's nominees deaf Patel fellow Asian
up there representing us I think they're
amazing actors very inspiring and
especially downsell Washington but of
the parts really there for these young
actors a lot of casting directors there
that really fight the calls of diversify
and all the programs that they work on
it's really to do with the people above
that that produces the ones that don't
have as much faith and belief there if
it did cost and I devised a diverse cast
that it won't lose them any sort of you
know revenue on the back ends I plan on
being an engineer ness and
anyway hidden figures is breaking those
barriers up for three Oscars knocks
rogue one off of the top spot in America
taking sixty million dollars in ten days
you go from a year where there's no
participation to this this wondrous
diversity that really it reflects not
only a healthier industry but it
reflects an artistry that is not as
limited you know it's not it's not this
tightly focused as it was this year's
Oscar nominations maybe the first baby
steps but Hollywood itself still has a
long way to go there's some debate about
whether or not Denzel Washington stands
a chance of winning Best Actor for
fences this Sunday but his co-star Viola
Davis everyone is tipping to win Best
Supporting Actress and Sky's Gillian
Joseph went to meet up how come you
never liked me like it's the antithesis
of Denzel Washington's action movies
based on a play by August Wilson fences
is set almost entirely in this backyard
and yet as well as award recognition
it's been a top ten box office hit in
the state rate look damn it he told the
story of the average black man he saw
the value in that story you know Alpha
Miller
you know said when he wrote really low
men that I know that these are not the
finest men who ever lived but a terrible
thing has happened to them so their
stories deserve to be told it's not easy
for me to admit that I've been standing
in the same place for
those are the stories The Chronicle
where we were as african-americans it's
those thousands millions of the average
black person who maybe wasn't educated
maybe didn't know how to read my father
didn't know how to read till he was 15
those are the stories that let you know
where we were
I'm glad August Wilson saw value in it a
man is supposed to take care of his
family and because the American
playwright insisted on a black director
it took 30 years to bring this story to
the big screen but now in the wake of
Hollywood's race rail its timing somehow
makes this film resonate more let's talk
about diversity future hour with the
Oscars last year about diversity of
actors in in films and films nomination
do you think that we've come over that
now do you think that the Oscars are
moving in the the right direction and
Hollywood's moving in the right
direction
it is moving in the right direction it's
directing because I think that people of
color are refusing to put Hollywood in
the driver's seat they are being the
instrument of change but I always say my
three biggest words were the question
mark at the end and now what Oscars are
going to be over February 26 and now
what what kind of films are being good
are gonna be produced what are the
storylines I go out of here every
morning I bust my butt but as one of
three oscar-nominated films with an
entirely black cast this simple story of
an American dad in the 50s represents at
this time so much more than perhaps even
its playwright could have imagined
Gillian Joseph Sky News that's all from
us in Hollywood and don't forget sky is
the British home of the Oscars and you
can watch the ceremony exclusively live
on Sky cinema all Sky Living from 11:30
on Sunday night you can join me on Sky
News live on Monday morning with
all the winners at the Vanity Fair party
bye-bye